why are you throwing shoes we're giving
Bush the boot i am nick gillespie with
recent TV and we're at Washington DC's
Dupont Circle where frenzied Obama
supporters are throwing shoes at a giant
inflatable george bush and we're asking
people about their hopes and fears for
an obama administration what's the
biggest change you want obama to make in
terms foreign policy i hope that he gets
the troops out of iraq as quickly as
possible I just like to see more unity
across the country really I would like
to see our views in the international
community shift around you know I don't
want as many countries resenting us but
I'd like to see some progressive gay
rights things go through I'd like to see
perhaps the legalization of marijuana
stem cell research mindfulness getting
rid of Bush I went an end to the war in
Iraq I wanted resolution Afghanistan and
I went to our standing in the world to
be restored so we really want to count
ability to mortgage company so we've
been doing nasty stuff to restructure
mortgages and make them affordable I
guess make all Americans feel like
they're included
you know their opinions and their
beliefs so new energy policy the foreign
policy healthcare I mean just endless
well so many but i would say we we need
to restore our dignity in the cut in the
world um bring the soldiers back does he
get mo clothes pc united states get out
of this whole war mongering mode get us
out of iraq get us out of afghanistan
and make a statement do the right thing
are for get us well we gotta do the
right thing about Darfur perhaps yes i
like to see them bring all of us
together as a people respect to the rule
of law changed to the middle east oh
Jesus an impossible question I'd like to
see more community action I love the
grassroots feel that he's bringing about
what's your biggest fear for an Obama
presidency my biggest fear is that he
won't be bold enough that he'll sort of
shrink and not live up to the occasion
and do bol things for example health
care reform afraid of the right-wing
people who are ultra conservative
not accepting him or the changes he
tries to make i'm not sure i might be a
little worried about what like the
conservative right is going to try and
come up with to you know inhibit any
progress who not be making bet he won't
get in four more years people they won't
make it for years that's my yahoo will
get through sabotage doesn't look like
that's happening so far it looks like
he's getting some cooperation from the
opposition that the hype is gonna be so
big they can't be lived up to that he
won't be able to
bring the economy back to life I think
people that that people are gonna start
not caring that people are honestly
gonna slip off and be like now that we
have our president we're gonna stay back
and let him do his own thing just that
he may cave in too much to the special
interest the same forces that which was
beholden to I fear for his safety I hope
that you know he and his family are safe
forever that it goes too far too far
left oh really so what are we reaching
far left what if he becomes a cult
leader it's getting a little culty